scenes from bygone days the queen
meeting heads of state and government of
the British Commonwealth at Windsor
Castle in 2018 by her side as former
Heir Apparent Prince Charles now King
Charles III the Commonwealth was very
important to the queen it remains a
great pleasure and honor to serve you as
head of the Commonwealth
and to observe with pride and
satisfaction that this is a flourishing
Network
it is my sincere wish that the
Commonwealth will continue to offer
stability and continuity for future
Generations the queen was the symbolic
head of the Commonwealth but many wonder
whether her son will be able to follow
in her footsteps as leader that's
because some of the 15 Commonwealth
Realms mostly former colonies where
Charles is officially King no longer
want the monarchy nor is Britain's
explicit leadership role in the
Commonwealth set in stone the new king
had already prepared for their say
observers such as David Howell a
long-serving commonwealth expert
King Charles he's very well versed in
all this he's been following it for
years he knows most of the countries of
the world but certainly the countries of
the Commonwealth he understands as very
few other not all other politicians
understand that we do need to make new
links in new Networks in November 2021
Barbados removed the queen as head of
state and declared itself a republic
within the Commonwealth
[Music]
the then Prince was invited but had
rather a supporting role at the ceremony
the creation of this Republic offers a
new beginning
and so a commonwealth of 16 States under
the British crown became 15 and it will
likely not stop there
Charles's son William toured the Bahamas
Belize and Jamaica in Spring 2022 his
father is now formerly Head of State in
all three but the three countries have
been recently making moves to change
that
rather than praised Prince William he
was greeted with criticism from the
public with a focus on slavery during
the British colonial era during the
visit the Jamaican president announced
the country's intentions to leave we are
moving on and we intend to
attend in short order
through ambitions
Independence
[Music]
developed prosperous culture but for
many Jamaicans this isn't enough they're
demanding compensation for the suffering
under colonialism
or economic conditions today are a
result of colonialism
or psychological problems are a result
of colonialism
or lack of development in every sense of
the word is a direct consequence of
colonialism
the future of the British crown is also
being debated in Australia the second
largest Commonwealth country however
there is support from the younger
generation for keeping Charles as the
nominal King the polling has shown that
my generation is actually the most
monarchist generation the most
Republican generation in Australia is
actually the Baby Boomers
um so and I know plenty of people on the
left who aren't necessarily
um monarchists but they support the
system we have because they don't see a
better alternative but can Charles
become a symbol of a new reformed
Commonwealth the leadership role of
Great Britain is historical but no
longer contemporary says Commonwealth
expert Howell
life has changed and the diplomats have
to face this and they have to get away
as it does the public from this sort of
vision of uh Hub and spoke well not
haven't spoke anymore when it works
within a partnership not the crown over
them that is
like-minded friends around the world
which we can talk to and the Richer ones
can help the poorer ones
at the recent Commonwealth Summit a few
months ago then Prince Charles spoke of
the British colonial era of the
suffering it caused so many people an
apology however did not pass his lips
if he is to succeed his mother Charles
III must pave A New Path for the Royal
House
for the one most Adept to change is the
one that survives